and I'm sitting there going like it's a
play they're not taking this seriously
and I'm having to kind of stand up on
the bottom of the Redwood knobs because
a lot of these guys are bigger than me
I'm only like 510 trying to get the
camera over so I'm kind of like up on
the tree and there's these guys are
looking at me all these old men and I'm
sitting there and I'm like I don't know
where's Clint Eastwood I just saw him
and
these old men are sitting there just
going because like like I'm a Christian
but you go to like a Holy Roller church
and they that it's great and it's
wonderful but they're like in Rapture
and you're like wow these people were
but like in a satanic type deal they
were just going oh
and I'm like and I'm like hey this is
pretty cool
oh my God I'm just like and Mike was
kind of hey how's it going they're like
this is important and so you're like
they're a dead serious